الدعني اسالك عن الاموال التي استثمرت في
الاتجاهات من الاتحاد الاوروبي تدفقت من
الاتحاد الاوروبي برغم العقوبات في اي
اتجاهات وفي اي قطاعات صرفت في روسيا
كبير جدا خارج القطاعي النفط والغاز
وخاصه في مجال التكنولوجيا لان العقوبات
اكثرها اثر انها كانت على قطاع المالي
وحيث وقطعتها حوالي كل بنوك الروسيه من
نظام سويفت والحاولات الدوليه وكذلك الحظر
على التكنولوجيا ايضا انتشر بشكل كبير
واضر بشكل كبير
بروسيا وسيكون اكثر اضرارا خاصه عقوبات
القديمه لان روسيا تجد من الصعوبه
سراج اي شيء قد يعتبر من الاستخدامات
الثنائيه
وهذا اثر على قطاع السيارات ومجالات كثيره
في مجالات كثيره من الاقتصاد بالتعليم
باتت اساسيه اما
الاشخاص او الشركات غير القادرين على
الوصول الى احدث التكنولوجيا او المنتجات
التكنولوجيه والمنتجات الاستهلاكيه
وكان هذا ربما هو اكبر انحدار او اثر فيما
يخص التجاره مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي اوروبا الحكومه تستمر
بالحديث عن
خططهم
لما سمى بتوطين الانتاج هنالك خطوه ناجحه
للتخلص من استيراد الغذائيه واصبح لديهم
اكتفاء ذاتي ونفس الشيء يمكنني ان يتم
التكنولوجيا ولكن هذا امرنا شك فيه لان
التكنولوجيا
ولم يتمكن من الوصول الى احدث التكنولوجيا
من اسيا واوروبا واولايات المتحده بلا شك
سيكون من صعب جدا استنساخها فهذا احد
المجالات ربما التي ستعاني فيها روسيا
بشكل كبير
بسبب هذا الحظر على التكنولوجيا